ja vielen Dank auch von meiner Seite
herzlich willkommen
möchte kurz in Eingangsstatement abgeben
zur
vergangenen Bundestagswahl ich möchte
mich da zuallererst bei unseren Wählern
bedanken die uns doch einen großen Votum
wieder in den Bundestag geschickt haben
dafür möchte mich herzlich bedanken wir
haben gezeigt dass wir ein starkes
Wählerpotenzial haben auch viele
Stammwähler die wir bei dieser
Bundestagswahl gehalten haben ich möchte
mich auch natürlich bei unserer Partei
bedanken für das große Vertrauen auch
die Vorschusslorbeeren die die Partei in
mich aber auch in Alice Weidel als
Spitzenkandidatin gegeben haben ich
denke wir haben das auch zurückgegeben
und zurückgeben konnten möchte mich auch
bei Alice weiter bedanken für die doch
tolle Zusammenarbeit als
Spitzenkandidaten Team wir haben sehr
vertrauensvoll zusammengearbeitet ich
denke wir haben ein aktiven
störungsfreien aber auch skandalfreien
wahlkampfbetrieben und auch das hat sich
im Ergebnis denke ich wiedergespiegelt
ich möchte mich auch bei meiner Familie
aber auch natürlich bei den
stellvertreten bei allen Familien
unserer Spitzenkandidaten unserer
Parteimitglieder bedanken die natürlich
diesen Wahlkampf mit unterstützt haben
sie haben doch auch erfahrungsvolle
sechs Wochen mit und unterstützt wir
haben unsere Familien in Stück weit
vernachlässigen müssen und ich denke da
gehört auch dieser Dank denjenigen die
uns dort in dieser Hinsicht unterstützt
haben insgesamt was das Ergebnis angeht
muss ich sagen haben wir ein sehr
stabiles Ergebnis erzielt in einigen
Bundesländern sogar der stärkste
Ergebnis bzw sind wir stärkste Partei
geworden wir sind gekommen um zu bleiben
das ist eingänglich auch schon gestern
erwähnt worden das ist eigentlich die
Botschaft die ich auch geben möchte 100
Prozent zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis bin
ich nicht unbedingt das muss man auch
sagen es gab eben doch regionale
Unterschiede im Ergebnis und wir haben
aber auch für uns als neue Fraktion
natürlich die Aufgabe hier eine Vision
für Deutschland zu entwickeln das wollen
wir natürlich auch weiterhin betreiben
in der Bundestagsfraktion aber auch als
starke Oppositionskraft im Deutschen
Bundestag im Bundestag
ich bin stolz auf unseren Wahlkampf auch
unsere Kampagne die doch wichtige Themen
angesprochen hat wichtige Interessen der
Bürger vor allen Dingen angesprochen
haben und ich bin auch stolz auf das
Ergebnis und ich bin auch stolz auf
unsere Partei vielen dank erstmal
sprechen können der Bundessprecher
bitte nee du bist zuerst dran und ich
wollte aus Höflichkeit den
Spitzenkandidaten den Vortritt lassen
aber sei es darum können wir gerne
machen ja meine Damen und Herren den
Dankesworten von tinoprophaler kann ich
mich nur anschließen dem habe ich auch
nichts hinzuzufügen und es ist wichtig
dass voranzustellen wir haben einen
Wahlergebnis das so Licht als auch
Schatten enthält das Licht liegt
sicherlich darin dass wir zweistellig
geblieben sind und dass wir uns
stabilisiert haben auf einem Niveau das
uns 2017 keiner zutraute positiv und
darüber freuen wir uns auch
zur Wahrheit gehört freilich auch und
das darf man sich nun wirklich nicht
schön reden
dass wir erhebliche Stimmenverluste
haben wenn man sich die
wählerwanderungen anschaut dann haben
wir eine SPD 260.000 Wähler verloren an
die
fdp210.000 sogar in die Grünen 60.000 an
andere 180.000 und selbst an die Union
die ein historisches debat erlebt hat
haben wir 80.000 Stimmen verloren das
heißt wir haben in alle Richtungen außer
der Linken von denen wir einen
Zuwanderung haben von 90.000 Stimmen
verloren wir sind im besten nirgends
über die zehn Prozent gekommen im Osten
nur noch in zwei Ländern über 20 Prozent
wir haben bei dieser Wahl das gilt es
nicht zu beschönigen knapp 20% unserer
Wähler verloren absolut sind das fast
900.000 wir haben in Landtagswahlen die
ja auch zu erwähnen sind verloren und
zwar in allen Landtagswahlen dieses
Jahres und nun bei der Bundestagswahl
auch Stimmenverluste dem stehen freilich
die positiven Effekte der
stammt von rund zehn Prozent entgegen
unter dem Strich wird man das als Erfolg
nicht vermelden können
Versuche sich das in einer Art von
Altparteien Manier schön zu reden darf
es bei uns nicht geben wir haben als
parteimotto Mut zur Wahrheit und dazu
gehört dann eben auch die Dinge nicht
schön zu reden wir sind angetreten um
die Politik in Deutschland zum Positiven
zu wenden das ist unser Anspruch an dem
wir auch festhalten und das gelingt mit
den Wahlergebnissen die wir derzeit
haben nicht wir müssen uns dann fragen
wie kann das geschehen
was was hat sich da zugetragen denn wenn
man sich vor Augen führt dass die Union
sehr sehr krass verloren hat dann hätte
eigentlich jeder gesagt mehr die neue
konservative freiheitliche Kraft die AFD
die müsste dann eigentlich ein Schub
bekommen stattdessen haben wir noch
schlimmer an die Union abgeben müssen
das ist unerfreulich und dann brauchen
wir
innerparteilich und das werden wir auch
innerparteilich tun eine klare und
schonungslose Analyse woran das gelegen
hat das werden wir machen indem wir
zunächst meine nachwahlbefragung in
Auftrag geben und dann werden wir sehen
wo die federlagen ich habe das ist
glaube ich von mir bekannt eigene
Erklärungsansätze wir haben in
Wahlprogramm wie sicherlich auch im
Spitzenkandidaten Duo unsere Kern
Klientel und wie ich finde das ist
ausgezeichnet gelungen bedient wir haben
die wirklich erfolgreich
bedienen können
diese Gruppe konnten wir zu 100% abrufen
das sind die 10,3 Prozent die wir haben
zugleich gehört zur Wahrheit dass es uns
nicht gelungen ist neue Wählerschichten
zu erschließen was ich immer anmahle
dass wir das tun müssen um wirklich
politisch erfolgreich zu arbeiten und
dann werden wir eben auch über
Komponenten des Wahlprogramms reden
müssen ob es wirklich klug war in das
Wahlprogramm zum Beispiel den
wechselforderung reinzuschreiben das hat
der Bundesparteitag so entschieden und
dann ist das so es war mir bekannt dass
ich das sehr skeptisch gesehen habe
ebenso wie Alexander gauland übrigens
ich glaube dass man damit sehr stark die
eigene Blase bedient
aber erhebliche Akzeptanzprobleme
außerhalb der Blase hat und das hat
Gründe die wir analysieren müssen und
die werden wir auch analysieren die
Gründe in medialer und
gesellschaftlicher Stigmatisierung zu
suchen halte ich persönlich für zu kurz
gegriffen deshalb weil wir das schon
immer haben seit wir antreten zu wahlen
sind wir in dieser Stigmatisierung wir
haben aber entgegen dieser
Stigmatisierung unserer Erfolge
eingefahren das heißt jetzt zu sagen die
Stigmatisierung ist der entscheidende
Grund wäre glaube ich zu kurz gegriffen
im konkluseo wir müssen weiter wachsen
wir müssen auf die Erfolgsspur
zurückkommen wenn wir in Deutschland
etwas und das ist der Anspruch den wir
haben zum Guten wenden wollen wir müssen
lernen aus aus diesem Wahlergebnis und
dürfen keine Tabus aufbauen wie die
Altparteien das gemacht haben schön
reden hilft uns dabei nicht diese
Analyse werden wir betreiben und dann
sehen wir mal was dabei rauskommt danke
schön Frau weiter bitte
also erstmal herzlichen Dank lieber Tino
auch an dich für den für den tollen
Wahlkampf wir haben mit den tausenden
von ehrenamtlichen Mitgliedern haben wir
einen enormen engagierten Wahlkampf
geführt
Infostände
organisiert Plakate aufgehängt
riesenveranstaltungen gehabt und
dementsprechend gilt auch eben der dank
insbesondere an den co-spitzenkandidaten
im Bundessprecher Tino kropalla der
wirklich ein super Wahlkampf hingelegt
hat ist kreuz und quer durch die
Bundesrepublik gefahren also ein super
Ergebnis in Görlitz eingefahren unserem
eigenen Wohnort über 50 Prozent also
wirklich ein ein Spitzenergebnis wir
haben uns etabliert als AFD man wollte
uns ja 2017 zu einer Eintagsfliege
einmalig in der Legislatur machen und
uns
2021 wieder Deutschen Bundestag
hinauswählen das ist ja seit gestern
bekannt nicht gelungen wir haben einen
stabiles Ergebnis eingefahren natürlich
ist es so dass wir uns das anschauen
müssen
in der Nachbetrachtung
Wahlkampfführung ist ein ganz großes
Thema
Personaldebatten innerhalb des
Wahlkampfes ein ganz großes Thema
natürlich denn man muss eins
konstatieren nichts Hass der Wähler mehr
als eine Partei die mit sich selbst
beschäftigt ist und da müssen wir
natürlich im medias Rees gehen und
darüber auch innerparteilich das
Aufarbeiten das wird in den Gremien
natürlich geschehen und allerspätestens
auf dem Bundesparteitag wenn der
Bundesvorstand neu gewählt wird
danke schön für die eingangstatements
dann kommen wir zu fragen die ist
natürlich
ihre Aussagen gerade wurde noch
belächelt von ihren Kollegen nehmen sie
neben ihnen verdankt hat man sich auch
nicht bei ihnen halten sie sich
eigentlich noch für einen guten fähigen
Parteivorsitzenden und Frau beide
hoppala ich rechne eine Annahme dass sie
mit den Leuten eigentlich nichts mehr zu
tun haben möchten
ach lieber Herr Jung
ich glaube wenn man eine
Personaldiskussion führt nach einer Wahl
dann führt man die nicht über ein
Parteivorsitzende sondern über das
Spitzenpersonal der Wahl wenn man denn
eine solche Diskussion führen möchte ich
halte diese Personalisierung für gar
nicht klug und halte die Frage von daher
auch fünf ein bisschen schräg gestellt
es gibt da unterschiedliche
Einschätzungen auch in der Zufriedenheit
mit dem Wahlergebnis ich glaube dass
wenn wir als als Partei wirklich
erfolgreich sein wollen dann müssen wir
unserem Anspruch gerecht werden und
unser Anspruch ist Mut zur Wahrheit zu
haben und wir können uns nicht in
Altparteien Manieren Ergebnis schön
reden
und deswegen spreche ich da auch
Klartext wir haben ja hier und da
Erfolge also zum Beispiel gratuliere ich
hier nur Propeller zu seinem zu seinem
Erststimmenergebnis in in Görlitz das
wirklich beeindruckend und damit hat er
das das Direktmandat auf eine tolle
Weise gewonnen es gibt weitere solcher
kleinen Erfolge aber wir müssen die
Partei natürlich wenn wir erfolgreich
arbeiten wollen im Ganzen betrachten und
im Ganzen ist das kein gutes Ergebnis
und unser Anspruch dass Deutschland
wirklich reformiert repariert werden
muss kann so nicht erfüllt werden und es
ist meine Aufgabe als Bundessprecher
dann auch zu schauen wo sind die
Defizite ob das von jedem Einzelnen im
tagesfall gutiert wird ist ein zweiter
Geschichte ich weiß dass sehr viele
Leute in der Partei diese Frage stellen
und wir müssen die stellen und wir
müssen sie auf Basis einer guten
Datenbasis dann eben auch beantworten
das werden wir tun das sind grundlegende
strategische Diskussionen und die
nächsten Wochen prägen
vielleicht ganz kurz Herr Jung auf ihre
Frage nein sie gehen nicht recht in der
Annahme
können Sie sich den Faschisten Höcker
als nächsten Parteivorsitzenden
vorstellen
alles du bist gefragt worden
ich hatte gefragt ob sie sich den
Faschisten höcke als Parteivorsitzenden
vorstellen können ich antworte auf die
Frage nicht halte für weil sie unseriös
ist nächste Frage
nächste Fragestellerin ist Frau Lindner
Frau Weidel eine Frage an Sie warum
haben Sie sich denn nicht bei Herrn
Meuthen mit bedankt und die nächste
Frage ist es ist jetzt ein bisschen
unklar geblieben wie die Partei jetzt
weiter agieren möchte um diesen
Wachstumskurs einzuschlagen erneuten
dann Frau Weidel welche Antworten finden
Sie denn auf die Frage die AFD wieder
auf den Wachstumskurs zurückzubringen
also erstmal habe ich mich spezifisch
bei Tino propala bedankt weil ich mit
ihm seit vier Jahren bereits im
Fraktionsvorstand zusammenarbeite Herr
gropala ist ja Vize-Vorsitzender mit
einer sehr verantwortungsvollen Position
ist seit fast zwei Jahren Bundessprecher
hat gemeinsam in jedem Wahlkampf gemacht
und das hat unwahrscheinlich gut
geklappt und darum auch der
ausdrückliche dankantinopropalla weil er
ja unterstützend im Wahlkampf gewesen
ist und das andere ist das habe ich
Ihnen dargelegt das werden wir intern
besprechen und ich muss ihn auch ganz
klar sagen dass ich das Ergebnis mir
nicht und uns auch nicht schlecht reden
lassen lasse von niemandem denn wir
haben nun mal ein solides Ergebnis
gefahren und das trotz des Dauerfeuers
seit Jahren gegen die Alternative für
Deutschland und dementsprechend sind wir
beide sehr sehr zufrieden damit und
[Musik]
das Ergebnis ist natürlich ausbaufähig
und das habe ich hier noch eben gesagt
da müssen wir uns intern besprechen
wie wir damit umgehen woran hat es
gelegen dass das ist auch wichtig dass
man sich das erarbeitet aber viel wird
natürlich an der zukünftigen
Bundestagsfraktionen liegen an der
Arbeit der Bundestagsfraktion und da
glaube ich dass ein vier Jahren die
Karten sowieso neu gemischt werden
oder die Frage auch an mich ging
wie wir uns das vorstellen nächstes Jahr
also wir mögen da wirklich eine
Differenz haben in der in der
Beurteilung wenn wir 20 Prozent unserer
Wähler Stimmen verlieren oder fast 20
Prozent dann halte ich Zufriedenheit für
unangebracht weil das nicht
zufriedenstellend darf wir haben einen
Anspruch wir wollen etwas erreichen in
diesem Land und wenn wir solche Verluste
haben und es ist ja nicht nur die
Bundestagswahl es sind auch die
Landtagswahlen wir sind in
Baden-Württemberg abgestürzt von 15,1
Prozent damals war ich der
Spitzenkandidat auf unter zehn Prozent
exemplarisch das darf man nicht
übersehen da muss man sich schon fragen
was muss man anders machen und da sie
Frau lindern die Frage stellen
ist von mir bekannt ich halte es für
notwendig dass wir
auch klare Signale senden in die
bürgerliche Mitte der Gesellschaft
hinein ich habe ich weiß nicht wie oft
im werden und auch quer durchs ganze
Land unterwegs
gehört von Bürgern im Gesprächen mit
Bürgern die hoch unzufrieden mit der
Union sind wir würden euch eigentlich
gerne wählen aber wir wählen keine
Partei die in Austritt aus der
Europäischen Union fordert das zum
Beispiel und darüber müssen wir uns
inhaltlich auseinandersetzen es geht
nicht um eine Anbiederung in das
bürgerliche Lage hinein wir sind sehr
fest in unseren Grundsatzpositionen aber
wir müssen sie auch glaubwürdig und ohne
einen Überschießen vertreten das ist das
was wir tun müssen und für diese
strategische Ausrichtung der Partei
werbe ich zusätzlich
Vertrauen zu Frau Weidel und Frau Weidel
haben sie noch Vertrauen zu erneuten sie
sitzen ja zum Beispiel gemeinsam auf dem
Bundesvorstand
wir arbeiten auch im Bundesvorstand
gemeinsam zusammen und wir treffen sehr
viele gemeinsam sehr viele gemeinsame
Entscheidungen sehr oft einstimmig
die
internen fragen wie die
Vertrauensverhältnis persönlicher Natur
sind die glaube ich wird niemand von uns
drei in ihnen hier in der
Bundespressekonferenz ausbreiten ich
jedenfalls werde das sicherlich nicht
tun
ganz kurz vielleicht noch mal darauf
eingehen Frau Linda auf das narrativ was
jetzt auch gesetzt wurde der
bürgerlichen Mitte das muss man
natürlich auch ein bisschen
unterschiedlich sehen das habe ich auch
in meinem eingangstatement gesagt
bezüglich der regionalen Unterschiede
also wir haben gerade in den
mitteldeutschen und ostdeutschen
Landesverbänden sehr wohl die
bürgerliche Mitte angesprochen also wenn
man Wahlergebnisse um die 30 Prozent
aufweisen kann dann hat man die
bürgerliche Mitte was immer das auch
konkret sein mag das muss man ja auch
mal definieren also wir springen immer
am heißen Brei herum was ist jetzt die
bürgerliche Mitte alle Parteien scheren
sich um diese wir haben gesehen dass
aktuell auch diese wählermilieurs und
auch die sternwählerschaften bei SPD CDU
nicht mehr so sind wie noch vor 10 15 20
Jahren also wir haben ja keine Heime die
an die 30 Prozent mittlerweile
bundesweit kommt und wenn wir in Sachsen
als AFD um die 30 Prozent an einigen
Wahlkreisen sogar überdeutlich über 30
Prozent bekommen dann haben wir dort die
bürgerliche Mitte eben angesprochen mit
unseren Themen mit unseren Inhalten aber
auch mit unseren Personen das muss man
einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen und diese
regionalen Unterschiede die gibt es im
übrigen bei jeder Partei die CDU hat
auch Unterschiede zwischen Nord und Süd
genauso wie die SPD zwischen Ost und
West diese Unterschiede hat auch die
Linksparteien im übrigen genau umgekehrt
also wir erleben dass es auch bei
unserer Partei natürlich Unterschiede
gibt die müssen wir anerkennen
vielleicht müssen wir einen Wahlkampf
zukünftig durchaus auch diese regionalen
Unterschiede mehr Gewicht verleihen dass
wir vielleicht in Bayern in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
thematischen anderen Wahlkampf machen
als vielleicht in Sachsen oder Thüringen
das ist durchaus möglich das werden wir
uns jetzt anschauen in der Auswertung
auch der der Themensetzung die wir
gemacht haben ich denke das wird auch in
Zukunft denke ich im Weg sein dass wir
diese Unterschiede ein bisschen
ausgleichen aber insgesamt jetzt davon
zu sprechen dass wir nur von der CDU
profitieren könnten CDU-Wähler
enttäuschen und dann alle dann zur AFD
Rennen das hat sich ja auch gezeigt dass
hier dieser polarisierende Wahlkampf auf
zwei Kanzlerkandidaten oder vielleicht
sogar drei Kanzlerkandidaten dort
gesetzt hat die Bürger dachten wenn Sie
die der SPD eine Stimme geben wählen Sie
den Kanzler den Kanzler Olaf Scholz und
das natürlich und ein bisschen Druck
Schluss gewesen was auch die die mediale
Berichterstattung angeht wir haben ja in
diesen Wahlkampf über Inhalte kaum
diskutiert es ging hauptsächlich um
Personen wenn ich allein auch das
Beispiel FDP sehe welches kernbeispiel
hat die fdu oder welches Kernthema hat
sie denn bedient sie hat in jedem Dorf
in christian-lindner plakatiert und das
hat augenscheinlich ausgereicht also da
muss man schon ein bisschen
unterschiedlich ansetzen wo am Ende für
die AFD die Wähler herkommen ob von
Linkspartei SPD oder CDU ist mir
wirklich gesagt herzliche egal wir
wollen Politik für alle Bürger machen
und das sollte eigentlich auch das Ziel
in der Zukunft sein dass wir auch von
anderen Parteien von allen Parteien
Werler Schichten abgreifen und da in der
Tat müssen wir nachjustieren
bürgerliche Mitte
Unterschiede zwischen Ost und West gibt
sie was bedeutet das noch mal für die
unterschiedliche Ausrichtung wenn man
diese vier Jahre im Bundestag Rückblick
betrachtet die Abstimmung die sie mit
der Fraktion
wie sie gemacht haben dann sind die
größten Übereinstimmungen tatsächlich
mit den sogenannten bürgerlichen
Parteien CDU und FDP gewesen
dennoch gibt es ja gerade im Osten
Stimmen in ihrer Partei die sich von
dieser Zielgruppe so ein bisschen
distanzieren wollen und mehr auf die wie
es dann heißt abgehängten oder die
Klientel der Linkspartei also so in
Richtung Vertreter in erster Linie des
Ostens
sich eher fokussieren wollen
wie würden sie das wie wollen Sie das
Lösen das muss ja eine inhaltliche
Klärung mal geben denn wenn Sie sehen
dass die Ergebnisse die
horrentenergebnisse an Prozentzahlen
sind ja in absoluten Zahlen nur die
Hälfte gewesen dessen was sie im Westen
bekommen haben
muss man natürlich erstmal auch das
wieder hinterfragen was jetzt konkret
meinen mit abgehängten Schichten allein
das ist schon so narrativ was sie jetzt
gerade setzen wollen es gibt
mittlerweile in allen Bereichen
abgehängte Schichten im Mittelstand im
Handwerk genauso wie auch bei der
Arbeitnehmerschaft also deswegen finde
ich auch das ist ja in Wähler Klientel
was wir bedienen müssen also was konkret
meinen Sie denn mit welchen Kurs wir im
Osten anders erfahren als im Westen oder
welchen Kurs habe ich jetzt als
Spitzenkandidat in Sachsen falsch
gefahren wenn ich diese Wahl mit zehn
Prozent Vorsprung zur CDU gewonnen habe
also das müssen Sie mir dann mal
erklären
eine Nachfrage ich meinte ja gerade im
Osten bei ihnen ist sicherlich
bürgerliche Schicht also sprich
Handwerker Mittelstand und so weiter
ihre Wählerschaft das ist im Westen ganz
anders und daraus gibt es ja aber
trotzdem in ihrer Partei das zitiere ich
jetzt nur die sagen wir müssen die die
generell frustriert sind die Nichtwähler
die sich Sorgen machen dass sie
Abrutschen in Hartz IV oder sowas dass
das die Klientel eher die zukunftsweisen
ist ja ich denke mal die
Frustrationsschwelle ist vielleicht im
Westen ein bisschen höher als im Osten
das muss man gleich auch mal anerkennen
und das gilt ein Stück weit auch
auszuhalten und abzuwarten ich denke
wenn der dir Herausforderung der
nächsten Monate und Jahre sehen was
Inflation angeht was Preissteigerung
angeht was der mietdruck auch die die
Mietpreise angeht wird es auch im Westen
die nächsten Jahre ein großes soziales
Problem auf uns zukommen und das dazu
müssen wir natürlich klar Kurs halten
und sicherlich auch thematisch anpassen
aber ich denke wir sollten uns nicht in
irgendeiner Weise Dingen anpassen
Parteien anpassen um kurzfristig
vielleicht wählersch suggerieren ich
denke der langfristige Weg ist richtig
ich habe mittlerweile in der Politik
gelernt dass hier auch Geduld gefragt
ist und ich denke die Ergebnisse im
Osten sind auch motivierend für die
Verbände im Westen